oh
the ground
get your hands get your hands do it now
oh my gosh I'm so sorry officials in
Wisconsin catch a would-be car thief in
action as he attempts to drive off in a
stolen vehicle at the Milwaukee Airport
body camera video captures the suspect
telling sheriff's deputies he's not all
there when he's taken into custody
all there I'm not all there right now
man
I just need help
that's all the incident happened on
April 5th at Mitchell International
Airport that's where officials say 23
year old suspect Sean jibbo started to
drive off in a stolen vehicle before
spike strips popped a majority of the
vehicle's tires body camera video shows
the moments Milwaukee County sheriff's
deputies catch up with jibbo
[Music]
the car
s
years ago
over here over here
[Applause]
oh my God I'm so sorry at one point
jibbo can be heard saying quote this is
not real I'm so sorry please don't
please don't could you hit me in the
back please don't
nothing
Davis
this is not real video from other First
Responders shows these same moments from
other angles
[Applause]
replace common custody right now I have
not been going I have not been knowing
what's going on
stop resisting
your hands
behind your back
get out the ground
stop resisting
get on the ground now this is not real
put your hands behind your back seconds
after a sheriff's deputy tases jibbo he
escapes and runs off
this is not real come on
he's running on one nice day
the white male black backpack
he's on foot going on 119.
he's running down one night see
westbound to the eastbound Lanes from
car rental
but eventually sheriff's deputies catch
up with jibbo
this one
somewhere
all right
as officials begin searching jibbo he
makes bizarre statements saying he needs
help and that there's fear in his heart
a lot of times
[Applause]
you search him yeah like completely
right here is this
stop talking all right hold on you spit
on mine
thank you
very nice
okay okay
it's not all there
I'm not all there right now man
I just need help that's all I was trying
to walk around and free my mind
everybody wanted to kick me out and they
wanted me to walk in this rain no fear
is in my heart
is
[Applause]
spread your feet
absolutely
over this right now
let go of it let go do you have any guns
weapons anything like that actually hey
assistant man take the take the watch
after Jibo is taken into custody
officials return to the nearly stolen
vehicle a sheriff's deputy can be heard
saying he believes jibbo attempted to
steal another vehicle the same evening
me and Briscoe actually ran into a
student in the upper Lobby and we kicked
him out of there so did he say he what I
hear you say earlier that he tried to
get into the second car there's another
set of keys for a Honda
dude I don't know because like I said
nobody knows what
I'm gonna just switch over to one and
let dispatch send a toe for this all
right
yeah I haven't sent a teleport now
411 dispatch
can you get a tow roll in for this
vehicle please Jibo now faces multiple
charges including operating a vehicle
without owner's consent and criminal
damage to property reporting for long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie